i mean we have to talk about it boxing
yeah
oh yeah
i'm sure you've talked about this to no
end actually not that much surprisingly
not that much let's go let's bring it
off
let's go i mean how how was that how was
that whole process it was so awesome uh
i will never do it again
yeah because like like i i love
everything i actually really loved
everything about it except for like
realizing like i feel my [ __ ] brain
moving when i get hit and i don't like
that
like being dizzy the day afterwards yeah
like a hard sparring is not it but like
everything like the training is cool
because you're working towards a goal
especially with create a clash you know
you're doing a thing
you paid to get in shape
exactly yeah i had the trainer comp i
had like the best trainer possible he
was great um he was like a golden gloves
champ in the state of california and
like almost the nation i think he
probably was uh goddamn yeah and so it's
like awesome but i won't do it again how
intense was like the training leading up
to us it was pretty intense like how
long did you have to do it for um so i
didn't have i i got in like near the end
of when they're getting people so i had
not as much time but i did it
um
i think generally it's you should do it
a lot it's like for me it was five times
a week um and then every day was like a
run before my coach got there he'd come
yeah and then we'd do like
jump rope some like pads um like hit the
bag some ladders yeah some just a whole
bunch of [ __ ] right and then it was
done so all in all it was like a good
like two
some hours three some hours every day
there's a lot of times yeah yeah it was
um it was good yeah we got like a lot of
sparring into as far as like the most
important part because you get to
actually see what
it's like it's like everything you've
learned up until then is gonna be like
sore all the time right
after sparring a little bit
um generally after like doing the
training itself for a while yeah you're
going to warm up for it yeah um but it
was very intense it was quite
interesting so how many like months were
you doing the five days a week um i want
to say like
like three to four months yeah
but it like there were like times when i
had to go somewhere on vacation not on
vacation but like go to another place
for like two weeks at a time and i had
to stop or like find a treadmill there
and just run right right right yeah yeah
[ __ ] it was the [ __ ] down the train yeah
i think no one thought it was gonna be
super intense or like if we were like
okay youtuber boxing whatever but then
like we saw how serious uh ian like
idubbbz was talking about yeah yeah yeah
and he'd come over like to every city
that fighters were in right and he'd be
like make sure we have a coach
everything we'd like meet his coach and
he's like yeah i'm training five times a
week i all i do is [ __ ] eat chicken
and rice and this is all i do i breathe
boxing and i was like holy [ __ ] you're
taking it really seriously did you like
adapt your diet as well to be like
a diet yeah i tried to just eat like
generally okay nothing intense yeah yeah
just as much like chicken and rice as i
could right like you know i'd sneak some
meat in there like some steaks and stuff
yeah that was fun chicken meat yeah yeah
yeah yeah
so how was the event itself because that
was awesome yeah because
we're just talking to lily about how
nervous she was just watching you get on
stage
yeah it was awesome though like the
place was filled out yeah um
the crowd was amazing they were just
like yelling non-stop freaking the [ __ ]
out yeah yeah it was just like it's such
a well put together event everyone looks
awesome yeah yeah so [ __ ] good i
can't like describe how it was walking
out it was amazing yeah what was going
through your mind when you were because
that must have been like holy [ __ ] this
is actually going to happen i'm actually
like it was kind of like mentally numb
at that point yeah i heard a [ __ ] my
song come on it's mine diamonds
i love that parody yeah yeah and that
made everything better yeah
all the world is right when you were
when you were walking in the rain were
you like i think i've got this like i
think um
you're good friends with that with
graham yeah yeah yeah we are um i
was feeling actually nervous up until
like we started and even when we were
going i
the first round was shaky for you yeah
yeah i was very unsure because like my
plan was to just gauge first the coach's
plan you know you engage first round get
them a little tired like play kind of
defensively and then in the second round
you can move off of that that's what i
was trying to do as much as i can right
but like
even following that plan i was like [ __ ]
he's kind of like hitting
i know he's getting me
i know this is the plan but i'm
still scared yeah i think there was a
moment where i was like i need to start
hitting him
and in order to win or i will lose yeah
yeah because obviously the points right
technical yeah yeah
and i felt like i was losing like the
entire first round but i think it went
even um
yeah it was complete like it was crazy
seeing it from the outside because it
felt
weird completely like this yeah like how
much
how much you remember being in the ring
do you remember like people chanting
your names because i do remember that
okay like i was like that's nice
shut the [ __ ] up
that did help out it was nice i was like
oh man these people are going to see god
damn lose
yeah it was amazing it was really cool
um yeah but it did like kind of shut out
everything else right you're supposed to
listen to your coach like they're
supposed to be calling [ __ ] and it's
like he could have been speaking
different languages
speaking in tongues
while you're fighting yeah you're
supposed to like listen
normally you're supposed to like your
coach is supposed to be like hey [ __ ]
take it downstairs jab get back on the
jab and like i'm listening to none of
that
is that like an amateur thing or is that
like you just when you're like for every
box i think every at every level you're
able to do that and i think it's a pro
level date because then they get to what
they actually get to see from the
outside and they'll be like okay it will
work if you go downstairs and hit the
body or whatever right yeah and so i
listened to him a little between the
rounds
a little bit yeah a little bit yeah did
you want some water yeah all right sure
yeah yeah it was uh it was super fun um
i my coach was uh training like three of
the people who were fighting so he was
busy as hell oh okay um
i and it was really official backstage
backstage was nerve-wracking because we
get there and there's like the blue
locker room and the red locker room uh
yeah that's where we're split up by like
the people who are fighting
not a lot of people know but before the
fight there was a pro fight in that same
arena just not streamed right and the
pro so there was one pro in our room and
one pro in their room and our pro got
tko first round of his fight and he so
he came back to the locker room and he
was like [ __ ]
[ __ ]
[ __ ] and everyone's just
like this is a giant
huge professional boxer pissed as [ __ ]
and so we're like all like nervous as
hell oh my god yeah really bad vibes in
our life the other one is like cheering
i heard after they were like yeah let's
go and then he goes out to the [ __ ]
minecraft
[ __ ] off yeah
i'm gonna cry yeah
yeah and then we had matt matt in our
room we saw him get just annihilated
we didn't get to see anything live until
after our fight so we're like in there
watching the tv and we watched the first
round like jaws hanging open like what
the [ __ ] is that how all of them are
we didn't know we were like yeah is this
what was happening what have we gone
ourselves into i'm gonna do that that's
gonna happen to me i was so nervous i
was just like sitting there not talking
to anyone will got some really good
footage of me just like sitting there
with headphones in just like listening
to music as much as i could so like how
how does like it compare to like when
you went sparring because like was it
something where kind of like your
experience just took over you know with
all the sparring i had to like try and
be kind of conscious about it i had to
consciously think like i will be making
these moves but like sparring it was
crazy too because in sparring i did like
like five six seven sparring sessions
with different people i never won like a
single round of sparring and you're not
supposed to you know you know you're not
winning in sparring right now it's not
counted who are you sparring my head
[ __ ] hurts after i lost that round
you know right um yeah uh so i sparred
against my coat first and he's like you
know a professional good and so he has
to like hold back so you're not fighting
someone really you're finding a good guy
who's holding back it's like when you
like hold back and smash against like
your girlfriend
no reaction she's right there
yeah and so i
bought him he shits on me constantly
obviously yeah um we went to another a
gym right uh and they were very nice we
were trying to find people for municipal
and there was this girl who's like
professional she's i was scared as [ __ ]
of her um i was like how long have you
been sparring she's like since i was
like nine and i was like okay that seems
fine and kick the [ __ ] out of you do she
that was the hardest i've been punched
she had the heart she hit me the hardest
out of anyone else
it was cool to see different techniques
because my coach is very like fluid and
all over the place yeah she had like in
incredible defense she'd like block
everything and frustrate the [ __ ] out of
you and then you come in and she'd like
have this really good check hook and she
just blast your head yeah yeah and like
getting hooked like that that was i even
felt the dizziest on that day yeah yeah
how many times a week are you sparring
he's like every single day
no um in the beginning you need to like
get up to snuff and then
and then when like my coach thought i
was ready um
once or twice a week yeah uh it's gonna
be scary though once twice a week yeah
yeah
getting your all speed yeah yeah and the
the the second one is like contingent on
how much you heard from the first one oh
my gosh um yeah so i got crushed by her
i got beat up by a 14 year old child i i
believe i saw some of the kids
he was really good i'm not even
embarrassed about that yeah he's really
good um he's like a national champion
for his age okay he's like the
he best really great he looks like aang
from avatar where he was like floating
around the ring
he was like moving just so much and like
and then get out and then he's like i
can't hit him
you know you and i've seen like every
anime where there's like a tournament
like in hunter you see the kid come on
you realize that you're the [ __ ] side
character
have you ever watched uh hajime no ippo
um i got clips from after the boxing
people were talking about it yeah
because i i think you did like one of
the i guess move similar to what they do
yeah
yeah you know dempsey's a real guy yeah
yeah yeah that's crazy it's just he just
he just took the move and kind of made
it like a more popular thing in the show
right yeah so normies know it but yeah
everyone knew it like yeah it's real
he's like one of the best right he was
very good yeah yeah damn he had like a
mike tyson style thing where he's like
and then
yeah exactly that's that's what like the
main character
without knowing it
yeah
power of golden anime uh it's like a
like a very good defense you're supposed
to shift against a hook right that's
when you're supposed to do the roll yeah
yeah
but most of that [ __ ] goes out the
window yeah yeah yeah yeah
i tried a boxing class like a few days
ago oh i saw it that was my coach you
know him yeah he was crazy like he was
so fast michael right yeah yeah yeah
when he was doing like he said no you
gotta do it like this i'm like what did
you just do i couldn't even see what
he's so smooth
okay
all right okay cool we're doing he's
like one of those anime characters where
he punches once and he's like actually
punched three times
but like four days afterwards my entire
body hurts yeah and dude like you can't
use your phone your hands yeah yeah your
thingies are [ __ ] up
we're like rubber he's like i couldn't
walk jesus i felt like i i look like an
idiot when i was walking full-time
commitment luckily i'm an american
that's true that's true but yeah it was
dude it was just like every workout was
a sprint yeah like i i thought i was
pretty fit because i do a lot of running
yeah running it was did not prepare me
for this yeah it's like you have to do
sprint training yeah it's like a full-on
cardio workout it's full on like
basically sprinting every exercise yeah
yeah yeah yeah no it really is like uh
when you're like doing the treadmill
you're supposed to like run in sprints
instead of just constantly yeah yeah
yeah yeah because it's like you're
trying to imitate the rounds right right
yeah yeah yeah it was [ __ ] up
no looking for a cool class though it
looks sweet yeah it was kind of cool i
mean i think it was like pretty big so
it's hard to really feel like you were
learning anything like yeah yeah
tailored to you but i mean it's good
though it was only like one class so you
know yes there's more room could you do
that five days a week for a month
okay i think i would like what i was
saying is like i think i would enjoy it
more if i was like just me and him and
then i could take my time and then right
you could really give me like all right
you're struggling here yeah yeah so just
be like all right twelve of you do jabs
and then you would maybe be like yeah
it's okay
yeah you know what i mean so it's like
am i actually doing it right i don't
know i want to go
but yeah no i i mean it seems i really
want to do it yeah it seems to be fun it
looks really fun but also
it looks terrifying at the same time was
there a point when you knew that you had
this because i like i i can't remember
which round it was but like you really
look like you were feeling yourself yeah
there was a point where like i like one
punch where i was like that really hit
his face
i was like
like turn him around and i was like that
and that was like very because i didn't
have a lot of confidence before that but
once i hit it i was like oh i can hit
i can hit him okay you can land the
punches i can land the punches yeah i
think i think alex said something
similar i asked him i met him the other
day and i was like when did you think
you'd want it he was like you said
something along the lines of like i
landed one jab and it was like oh okay
and it's like i i know i'll do it again
yeah oh i'll just do that i just gotta
do that
i imagine when you [ __ ] see the guy
doing like a a kind of uh punch-out kind
of falling over wobble yeah yeah all
right i think i'm pretty good like i
think it's going well yeah there was a
point where i was like getting mad i i
don't like the camera didn't really
catch it because i'm glad i like hit him
with
one shot like right hand i was like
[ __ ] [ __ ] you were hitting me
and [ __ ]
i'm gonna use that energy though right
yeah yeah
what do you mean you're not just a
sandbag taking my punches
oh my god that's crazy around it got a
lot better yeah i mean yeah you looked
amazing and it i think the whole event
was just so [ __ ] awesome yeah yeah i
i like props to everyone who like said
yes because i mean did you know going
into it like how big of a deal it was
going to be no no he was just like you
wanna do a boxing thing right right you
must not have like known it was gonna
turn out that way yeah it did not no
idea yeah i didn't know it was gonna be
that big or that serious yeah ian's a
madman dude
yeah yeah yeah he took it very seriously
he's very good yeah massive props yeah
[ __ ] brought like everyone up with
him though with how serious he's doing
which is like really respectable
considering
like the youtube boxing scene nowadays
yeah it kind of feels like a clown show
sometimes you know
now there's like i think three more like
more serious events going to pop up soon
uh inspired by like the yeah stuff so
hell yeah
it's gonna be like it's like there's the
best league it's like oh if you're a big
youtuber he gets going the big one
everyone under that bar of interest 10
million yeah it's like instead of
instead of getting like a shitty plaque
and you had 100k they're like odd go and
join the little league
like susan watches
your glass
100 people versus mike tyson
yeah
it's like the next generation gladiator
yeah
i mean that's basically what it's
turning into right yeah
because it's just like fun to see your
favorite creators do like a totally new
thing [ __ ] yeah they would think it was
weird seeing like ian and even like like
ryan go up there it's really cool matt
yeah for his fight yeah that was crazy
when did you find out who your opponent
was um
uh like like a few weeks after i agreed
i i think they were looking for someone
for me for a while yeah um he was gonna
put me against [ __ ] captain sparkles
who has been boxing for like years
and he's like watching for years and
he's like 80 pounds heavier than me
so you just die
not only that i don't think the boxing
commission would have let us fight i had
to like be within 10 pounds of gram i
actually was i so i went to florida i
think i was like 124. yeah i got to
florida check the next day i was like
122. and then
on the day before the weigh-in they're
like okay go on the scale just to see to
make sure because graham was like 129.
okay right uh no no he's one like 32.
and
i was like 119. i lost so much like
water weight in florida and so like the
hour before the thing non-stop drinking
water
needing to piss so bad i gained like i
think i gained three and a half pounds
in one hour just by drinking water oh
and drink like enough water yeah yeah
yeah yeah full of piss
i needed a piss so bad before the fight
yeah um but what happens they they'll
wrap your hands and the boxing
commission has to sign off on it and
then gloves and they have to sign off on
it so you can't take them off so i was
like man i kind of got a piss but what
am i gonna do and the guy who was like
warming me up who was michael's friend
he was like
i got you i've done this before and we
[ __ ] and he's like come on anyway go
in the bathroom and i have like my [ __ ]
guard on and my pants and he's like okay
i'm just gonna i got you and he just
grabbed it and like stood behind me and
pulled it down and i had to like use the
thumbs of the boxing gloves
and so i just like stood there pissing
and he was like holding it
in america it's like a drinking game oh
that's that sounds pretty cool
okay yeah so that's what it sounds like
to me yeah yeah
just like so
so what's edward 40 hands is it it's the
same thing same thing yeah
because we call edward side of hands in
australia okay and american said with 40
hands right yeah because you're doing
40s yeah like a bottle of 40 ounces yeah
so basically you get like a bottle of
cider or 40s like literally taped on to
your hands and you've got to finish it
uh before you can take them off so at
one point you're going to need to go to
piss
and it's it's it's really really [ __ ]
difficult
right hopefully and then hopefully you
can you can pee yeah dude i'd [ __ ]
lose that [ __ ] like my blood my bladder
is like [ __ ] tiny my bladder is
absolutely all my skill i had i had a
weird thing where it like felt like it
popped one time like i had to piss
really bad at this restaurant yeah with
the bladder popped and i was like in the
end of a line yeah and i went to the
bathroom it took super long and like as
i like you know how you kind of suck in
and you're like taking your hands off
and like i'm not sucking it was like
i like felt something and like my vision
started getting like
black around the eyes oh my gosh
just like very painful and dizzy and i
finished the piss and i went out and i
sat on the ground for like 10 minutes
and but then i was fine but i think i
can't hold as much piss after that
it's like i permanently sacrifice what
did you do dude
you just debuffed your bladder even
though i have to piss so bad there's
water
your toilet
now let's take a toilet